why do you say the movie business is a
weird business
well
yeah among other things it's a
it's a
it's it's a business that
people really really really want to be
in it and be successful at it and make a
living so it attracts
interesting characters a lot of the time
um
it attracts people that
that
you know risk takers it attracts people
that let's be real
can't always be
conforming into a corporate environment
they wouldn't do well in there it's not
always they wouldn't do well because
they didn't want to do well so sometimes
this data wouldn't do well because
people would have a difficult time
dealing with them so you're dealing with
people
that really really want to make
this thing work but it's very difficult
to make work
so
when you
[Music]
get into it and there's people around
you
trying to make their film careers work
trying to make their
movie and television careers work
you get people that
you know take that just will do strange
things and
um
you know stab you in the back stab their
friends in the back um uh you know
snitch people out it's it's very
it's very um
you know it's it's there's a lot at
stake
because the rewards are amazing you know
it's the best business in the world
and not everybody can be in it so once
you get your foot in the door
and you know you
can feel yourself maybe slipping maybe
not going as way it's supposed to you
can people can hold on super tight to
try to stay in the business
to try to
you know make it not my fault um you
know this i was told this this guy told
me to do this and you know you know all
this different stuff and
uh you know
um so it's that and it's also a little
weird um
you know because it's just it's just a
a business that not everybody can
would want to be in it's just it's
uh although the glamour parts
cool you know glamorous and red carpets
and everything else but but when rubber
hits the road it's a lot of
disappointment
it's a lot of rejection
it can be
incredibly hard work
sometimes for
little or nothing as you're establishing
yourself
and um
you're dealing with interesting
characters you know it's you know
i doubt it's like selling insurance like
you know you're gonna look at insurance
salesman and the manager and the
regional manager i mean you get some
people from
the drug world you get people from
uh uh criminals you get
people that are
come in that made money in some other
field
and just come in and want to do this and
so
it's uh it's it brings people from all
different areas and all different walks
of life and so maybe weird is not the
the best term but it's you it's
interesting for sure
not for the faint of heart no no do not
you
you have to be tough as nails to be in
this business you know
i say that people in film business
are some of the most
some of the best employees you'll ever
have
in any work because you can't make
mistakes
it's one of the one of the one of the
only
um
one of the only professions where you
cannot make a mistake and you walk
around
knowing i can't make any mistakes i
can't make a mistake it's oh that's okay
no you lose your day
you can't lose your day you can't lose
your sun
meaning the sun light you know you can't
mess something up and hurt an actor you
can't you know you there are no mistakes
and so you you approach every day
uh with that in mind
so everything and of course mistakes are
made
but you still have that
mindset
no mistakes
and you live with that so
and
there's also the element of wanting to
be agreeable and easy to work with but
knowing that
some things on the surface are not what
they appear to be
and to watch your back but keeping a
smile on your face
yeah being agreeable you know it's a
it's a big deal you know
most of what i when i
interview people especially actors to
come down to mexico it's all temperament
to me i mean i'm sure they can get i'm
sure i can get them to where they need
to be
performance wise
but
temperament anything see it's not like i
said before it's not like we're calling
somebody to go to north hollywood and
they live in burbank
you have to take them there and host
them there for three weeks a month two
months
any piece of their personality
that's unmanageable
will come out in those three weeks
believe me it's going to come out you
need to make sure these people have
that kind of
are stable in that way and not gonna
and there's ways to tell you know you
can just
you can just talk to them about things
and
and and
see and let them know look
it's things are not gonna go perfect
they're not but how you deal with that
can you can you adjust can you pivot
are you going to be cool are you going
to make a nightmare scenario for
everybody are you going to call your
manager and say uh you know that this
guy didn't give me there was my
yellow candy wasn't
there and these this is a nightmare and
this is and then create that toxic
energy inside the set
so
how people people's
temperament is everything to me
um
because you have to live with them i can
put you on a plane
where you wouldn't want to be with
somebody for three hours
much less three weeks
and and the
you know you have to really
kind of be able to know that and so
i have a very calm demeanor all the time
i'm cool about stuff
all the time i can adjust and pivot
um but dealing with people that are
bullies and things like that can be
really really problematic and they in in
the end they end up costing money
and
and causing problems
all around
you know so so we learned to kind of
look for that first
even before the talent and then we move
to
can you do it
suppose someone's easy to work with
what about trust factor
how do you determine that
trust as far as
although there's many levels of trust
just uh maybe
trust in terms of um
i guess there's probably different
layers of it so trust
being on the set
trust
having them as someone you would
continually call back okay trust in your
quote unquote and for lack of a better
term sorry inner circle
yeah um
you you know one thing you learn
in film is that you gotta keep your film
circle relatively small
um but i have built over time people
that i genuinely trust
and
um but it takes a little bit of time and
you need to see them in various
situations
um everything's going smooth you don't
know whether or not you can trust them
in a in a in a jam
anybody that's done
any kind of
decent number of independent films has
been in a lot of jams
and it's how you deal with that and you
watch them and you you analyze how they
deal with that and at the end of the day
are they
trying to
be toxic and turn everybody against
everybody
or at the end of the day are they having
a drink and saying that they
sucked but i think tomorrow is going to
be better
i'll take the guy
who says
i have the drink with and tomorrow's
gonna be better
with the less talent
over the other guy
or girl that is causing the problems
you have to realize
we're in
where we're in you're basically in a
foreign country you're very vulnerable
you can't have
revolts and you know strikes and things
like that this is very dangerous
and so you you you know you can't even
and you can't have people walking off
you know you have somebody that your
sound guy ah forget about this i'm
walking who's gonna do the sound i mean
you can find somebody but you see what
i'm saying you have to
be able to trust that people are gonna
put the movie first
and
not make it about them all the time you
know
so i think so i think that trust in that
way
um
and just and just time
you know you have to have been through
things with people so that you
understand how they'll react and and you
can trust them to be there in when
things get a little chaotic
and they'll
keep themselves centered and focused
during that time because chaos
working within chaos is something you
must learn to do
and pressure high pressure chaos
um
and pivot
you know be able to
we're gonna shoot here
okay but the car's not here turn around
shoot the other way
until the car gets here
so you have to be able to pivot without
saying you know i can't believe the
car's not here this is
you know like you just got to just
figure it out and just keep moving you
know so
you find people that you know will do
that crew we have now will
100 do that
they pivot without a problem so i have
tons of trust in them